well saturday marks the 20th anniversary
of 9 11. and this week we've been
sharing stories as we remembered that
day and one person on our eight news now
team has a personal connection to
someone who was on the front lines the
i-team's vanessa murphy here now with a
very special person to her vanessa yeah
denise like many las vegas locals i
didn't grow up here i'm originally from
new york that's where most of my family
is including my grandfather who helped
take care of some of the 9 11 victims
he's in queens new york so he talked on
zoom about his experience
i was like it's like a war zone this is
my grandfather dr james mazzara at 83
years old he's now retired but on
september 11 2001 he was chief of
clinical cardiology at saint vincent's
hospital in new york city
we were a mile and a half north of the
twin towers
he was heading a fellowship program at
the time and he recalls receiving word
during a teaching conference the chief
resident came in and said a plane had
crashed into the one of the twin towers
they prepared to treat patients the team
first thought what was unfolding was an
accident but then the second plane hit
the second tower that's when things
looked
more ominous
at the time patients arrived with trauma
injuries from debris that had fallen
some had respiratory symptoms many were
covered in dust he says this continued
through most of the day and he slept at
the hospital that night things start
started to
slow down and that was a sign to us
that things were not looking good the
realization many did not survive these
were you know innocent people almost 3
000 non-military people who had their
lives destroyed their families
changed forever and many of those
families posted notes as they searched
for their loved ones hoping they would
turn up safe at places like saint
vincent's it was a tragic time
like many new yorkers and americans for
my grandfather the 20th anniversary of 9
11 stirs up emotions and memories that
are difficult to accept from
the floor we were on in the hospital we
could actually see one of the towers
with billowing smoke
uh coming from it
so i mean i'll always i'll always
remember that
makes you think how fragile life is
st vincent's hospital was a level one
trauma center considering this and its
close proximity to the world trade
center that's why many patients were
brought there the hospital closed in
2010 and that's when my grandfather
retired today at the site of the world
trade center there's a 911 memorial and
museum